el 49-3 el artículo utilizado para
impulsar la polémica reforma de las
pensiones este jueves y en el derecho de
replicar el parlamento francés en forma
de votos de censura dos de ellos se han
presentado este viernes y se espera que
se voten el lunes los que penden de un
hilo son la primera ministra Elizabeth
bone y su gabinete bona utilizado el 493
para evitar una votación parlamentaria
un cbc desde que asumió el cargo del año
pasado lo diferente esta vez Es que hay
una nueva posibilidad de que los
partidos de la oposición se unan detrás
de una alianza no partidista de
diputados conocida como el grupo liots
el grupo libertad independientes
territorios de ultramar
presentará una moción de censura con 91
firmantes de cinco grupos de la
oposición Lamento que mis colegas blr no
sean firmantes Pero espero que muchos
voten a favor
ha sido firmada por independientes y
miembros de la coalición de izquierdas
nupes El poder de hacer o deshacer esta
Alianza está en manos de los diputados
del partido conservador los republicanos
sus líderes han descartado apoyarla pero
algunos legisladores han dicho que
romperían filas la ultraderechista
agrupación nacional presentó una segunda
moción que previsiblemente obtendrá
menos respaldo Aunque una diputada dijo
que su partido votaría a favor de todas
las nociones de censura presentadas para
ser aprobada una moción de censurar
requiere un mínimo de 287 votos más de
la mitad de la asamblea nacional
talazania obligaría al gobierno a
dimitir otra opción para macron sería
despedir a la primera ministra Elizabeth
que ha estado al frente del debate sobre
las pensiones